take us back to your sick days when you
said you knew you risked arrest you knew
you risk not village finishing colleges
that many other folks how did people you
young people think about this
financially in in Harry Belafonte is a
memoir that was just published he notes
that there were hundreds and thousands
of people and young people and children
that were arrested in Georgia and in
Albany Georgia for example and you had
to post bond and bail where did they
think the money would come from and
oftentimes there wasn't money and one
had to raise money in the north and
elsewhere to get these folks released
from prison how did you and others put
yourself at risk without the resources
of who would pay your bail well probably
foolishly we didn't know the resources
were there when we risk going to jail I
don't think we thought that far in
advance that when I was arrested in
Atlanta for the first time I did not
think Joe Blow will pay my bond I didn't
know Joe Blow I didn't know who might do
it in fact I don't think I ever thought
about at all I knew I wasn't going to
spend the rest of my life in jail and as
it turned out I spent just an afternoon
and someone i did not know stepped up
and said I'll pay not my bail but the
bail for all of us are several some but
someone's I happen to live in Atlanta at
the time a community which had enough
people black people of wealth and not
enormous wealth but just ordinary wealth
who could say well I'll put up this I'll
put up that I'll put it out and we could
all get out it's never a problem when
you got in a smaller southern towns it
was a big big problem and you had to
reach outside of your own circumstances
to get people to do that but luckily we
could always find people to do it
there's always a scuffle always a
struggle but there was always somebody
who'd do it some somebody's who would do
it because never what what could one
person take care of this but they're
always somebody's who could do it and it
always turned out well well in the end
you know where we were and are the kind
of people who said I don't know who's
going to do it but somebody will I
believe that will happen and we believed
we just had this trust that it would
happen
it always did do you have examples of
that today sure today I went to with you
to talk to a wealthy man who I wanted to
give money to the n-double-a-cp and I
can remember that my wife and Maxim and
myself just scratch eyes before God you
say this then no don't say that say this
then I'll say this then you'll say that
and so on finally we got the guy and I
spoke in my wife spoke and Maxim spoke
of the guy said what do you want and
maxim said a million dollars and he said
I can do that I'm is none of us jumped
up and said whoo-whoo but I think we
felt that and this guy gave us a million
dollars and you know we often wondered
what if we had said what if you had said
a hundred thousand I think we would have
gotten that but it's not as good as a
million so we said a million and he gave
a million and he's a decent kind of
person and I think if asked would do it
again but so you ask and you get not
every time by any means but you do it
get it if you ask for it and you won't
get it if you don't ask for it